Hello there, I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We're the Slow Mo Guys.
Back when we first
started this channel, Dan,
before we really knew
what it was all about
we used to do a lot more challenges.
We did, like competitions between us.
Yeah.
Why don't we first of
all go back to our roots,
see who can shoot this candle out?
I think I've got an advantage here.
Because you shoot guns and I don't?
Yeah, and you're scared of them.
I've seen you try.
What's the penalty for losing?
Football to the head?
I suppose so, yeah.
I think I'll get my revenge here.
We'll be shooting this
on the Phantom v2511
at 28 thousand frames a second,
and we're gonna position
the camera behind the candle
just to prolong the amount of time
that the pellet is on screen,
because it still moves pretty fast.
Oh, I hit the candle.
You did?
Yeah, but it wasn't the top of it.
Look at that.
Can't believe it stayed lit.
Yeah.
That's quality.
Just an inch off.
That was a good first try.
Oh you actually got it!
You actually hit it!
No, I went straight through it.
Oh.
I went straight through
it, knocked it out.
Oh, you knocked the flame out, though.
I was like no way!
Because I saw the flame go
out and the candle move.
I was like, you hit it.
I just blasted straight through the wick,
by the looks of it.
Has that blasted the wick out of the way?
I don't know, maybe it missed the wick.
Is that a win?
I don't think that's a win.
Okay, so I has to hit
the actual top bit here.
You could say that shot was
Wicked?
Yeah, got it.
Oh, so close!
I think I was so close.
So close, I can almost
feel the satisfaction
of lobbing a football at your head almost.
Dammit, you're getting closer.
I am.
Oh, did I get it?
Either, right, either
you've got the perfect shot
or it just happened to
go out at the same time.
I'm hoping for the second option.
Or maybe you didn't go anywhere near it.
Oh, it was a glance.
Oh, the wax, the wax blew it out.
Oh, that was so close.
Goodness me.
Lucky escape.
That was very close.
Happy with that.
Dammit, I thought I had it.
So did I.
How close was that?
That's just a complete miss?
Oh, I got it!
No!
I reckon I got it!
Yeah, yeah, oh yeah.
Oh no, no.
No?
No.
That's it.
Oh, you hit it again!
You just keep slapping that bit.
See if that was a premature celebration.
Oh that counts, come on.
That counts, it's got to.
The wick went flying, look!
I've hit the wick.
You didn't hit the wick.
The wick completely bent, it moved.
What happened was you hit the wax,
which sort of shock wave blasted.
You hit the wax .
Well, I'm happy to give that to you,
it's just do you want to see
a shot where it hit the wick
as the winning shot?
It's up to you.
You can take the win on that
if you think you deserve it.
I mean, I absolutely deserve it.
Yeah?
But.
All right, how about this?
We'll keep going.
If any of us hit the wick
we'll trump that victory.
If not, you win.
Okay, that's a deal.
Oh!
No.
It went through.
Oh, so close.
Blew it out the underneath.
Whiff.
Oh, you got it!
Are you serious?
You actually got it, yeah!
You frayed the wick.
You actually hit the wick, you got it!
I don't believe it.
No!
What are the chances?
You actually nailed it.
You have to have done.
Look at the wick, that's been hit.
Right on the tip, as
well, right on the tip.
Oh!
It could not, that is so clean!
Couldn't be more perfect.
That is the cleanest shot.
Look, it almost relit
it, it was that clean,
through the smoke.
I feel good about it.
You know, I actually feel
like taking the win with that
just because yours was good,
but that was so crisply clean.
That was so clean.
Yes!
Hard to say I'm not goaded about that.
So we're shooting against this fence,
which thankfully there's nothing behind
the other side apart from trees,
but they went through.
One of them went through.
Look, you can see if you
look through this one,
there's a hole actually goes through.
This one, you can see the pellet
stuck in there still.
Weird.
Over here, there's one over
here, there's one here.
Not the best grouping.
Naturally, yeah, well
these are clearly my shots.
Oh okay.
Yeah, your ones are like that one there,
that one there.
One over there probably.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly yeah.
Such satisfying shots from that.
That closeup, perfect!
So crisp.
So crisp, love it.
And I can't believe I won.
I am rubbish at shooting.
I'm devastated.
I'm actually goaded, because not only
did I lose against you at shooting,
I also have to have a football
at the side of my face again.
But this time, with this camera,
so 28 thousand FPS.
It was a thousand last time.
Any excuse, goodness sake.
Hopefully you enjoyed
that little challenge.
I think we should do more
of those every now and then.
I still enjoyed it.
Yeah, satisfying.
I usually win stuff like this, though.
You usually do, not on camera though.
That's all that matters, isn't it?
No one cares about anything else.
Feel free to follow us on Twitter.
Definitely watch some videos
on our second channel.
They're pretty top, and subscribe.
Buy a T shirt.
Buy a T shirt, buy a poster.
Pop the kettle on.
Before I leave you, I
recently did a collaboration,
which is something I hardly ever do,
but it's one of my favorite channels
on the whole of YouTube, Corridor Digital.
We made a full-out four-themed video.
Lot's of slow mo and lots of
me running around like a fool
so be sure to check it out right here.
Yeah!